we're on problem 66 and it says what is
x squared minus 4x plus 4 divided by x
squared minus 3x plus to reduce to
lowest terms so they probably want us to
factor each of these quadratics and then
see if any of the terms cancel out so
let's try to do that so the numerator
let's see this seems pretty easy to
factor what two numbers when i multiply
them equal four and when I add them
equal minus four well it's minus to
write minus 2 minus 2 is minus 4 minus 2
squared is plus 4 so this is X minus 2
times X minus 2 and you could test it if
you don't believe it multiply that out /
let's see what two numbers this looks
factorable they both have to be the same
sign because you multiply them you get a
positive right and they're both going to
be negative because when you add them
you get a negative 3 so let's c minus
two and minus one right minus two x
minus one is positive 2 minus 2 plus
minus 1 is minus 3 so X minus 2 times X
minus 1 and then if we assume that X is
never equal to 2 because that would make
this expression undefined we cancel that
out you learn later that would cause a
hole in the graph because it's the
function is undefined there and you're
left with X minus 2 over X minus 1 and
that is choice a a problem 67 whether
this is good practice they give a bunch
of it they say what is so this is 60
I'll just write it 12 a cubed minus 20 a
squared over 16a squared plus 8 a
reduced to lowest terms so let's just
try to factor out things on the top and
the bottom and see what happens so the
the top in the numerator let me switch
colors see both terms are divisible by 4
and a squared so let's factor out a 4 a
squared so we get 4a squared for 12 / 4
is a 3
and a cube divided by a squared is an a
right so 12 a cubed divided by 4a
squared is 3a minus 20 I mean I could
say plus minus 20 but you get the idea
20 / force 5 and a squared divided by a
squared is just a and if you don't
believe this multiply it out 4a squared
times 3 is 12 a cubed and 4a squared x
minus 5 is minus 20 a squared so it
works out we do the denominator let's
see both of these invisible by 8a let's
factor that out 8a 16 / 8 is 2a squared
divided by a is a all right so 16a
squared divided by 8a is to a and if you
go the other way 8a times 2a squared is
16 a squared so it all works out plus 1
right 88 x 1 is 8a so let's see what we
could do here so this this becomes a 1
this becomes a 2 and then a squared
divided by a divide both of them by a
and you get this becomes a 1 and this
becomes just an a and we're left with a
times 3a minus 5 over 2 times 2 a plus
one and let's see that is yes that is
choice D I thought maybe they want us to
ream ulta ply this out again but that is
choice D problem 68 68 68 oh this is a
good one let me I'll just fry this one
is to multiply something so they say 7
whoops 7 z squared plus 7 z all of that
over 4 z plus 8 times Z squared minus 4
all of that over Z to the third plus 2 Z
squared plus Z equals so you might say
oh my god i have to multiply all of
these things and have to divide them but
the best thing i'm guessing is to just
factor these out and do all sorts of
things will start cancelling out with
each other and it'll turn into a pretty
simple problem
so let's see both of these terms are
divisible by 7 z so let's factor that
out so that top part becomes 7 z x 7 z
squared divided by 7 z just have a Z
left right all right if you multiply
these you get 7 z squared plus 1 right
if you multiply this out you get 7 z
squared plus 7 see the denominator so
let's just multi-unit multiply fractions
just the numerator times the numerator
over the denominator times the
denominator so let's just keep mom so
this is times the numerator z squared
minus 4 that's a squared minus B squared
so that's Z plus 2a plus B times Z minus
2 a minus B alright that's just the
pattern when I say all that A's and B's
so that's Z plus 2 times Z minus 2
hopefully you can recognize that at this
point and then all of that over let's
see we can definitely factor out a 4
here so it's four times Z plus to write
for Z right 8/4 is two times and let's
see if we can see we can definitely
factor out a Z here so we get times Z
times Z squared plus 2z plus one I think
we're almost done now we have to factor
this let me just rewrite everything so
this is equal to seven Z times Z plus
one times Z plus two times Z minus six
all of that over four times Z plus two
times Z and what's this this is Z plus
one squared right Z plus 1 times Z plus
1 1 times 1 is 1 and 1 plus 1 is 2 so x
z plus one times Z plus 1 & now's the
fun part we can get this is a 1 here the
parentheses now we can start cancelling
out and we assume that the denominator
and every equals zero and all of that
let's see the Z plus 2 cancels out with
this Z plus 2 this Z plus 1 cancels out
with one of these Z plus ones I'll do
the ones written Messier and let's see
this Z cancels out with this Z and what
are we left with everything simplified
27 times Z minus 6 over 4 times Z plus 1
and that is that is not oh you know what
I think I 19 Z that's that's Z I wrote a
Z minus B here Z plus 2 times Z minus 2
all that pattern matching I made a
mistake right z squared minus 4z plus 2
times Z minus 2 naught Z minus B and I
thought that was a sick so this is Z
minus 2 right there so this is Z minus 2
and so that is choice a sorry about that
that error brain malfunctions all the
time all right now they want us to do it
again they want us to find the product
okay of X plus 5 over 3x plus 2 times 2x
minus 3 over X minus 5 frankly there's
not a lot of simplification we can do we
just have to multiply it out so this is
going to be equal to X plus 5 times 2x
minus 3 all of that over 3 i'm just
multiplying the denominator i'm
multiplying the numerator and then
multiplying the denominator is 3x plus 2
times X minus 5 and now we just multiply
both binomials do it in green x times 2x
2x squared x x minus 3 minus 3 x 5 times
2x Plus 10 x 5 x minus 3 minus 15 enough
navi to the denominator three x times x
is 3x squared 3x x minus 5 minus 15 x 2
times X plus 2 x 2 x minus 5 minus 10
and now let's you can simplify we have
the numerator is equal to 2x squared
minus 3x plus 10x so that's plus 7x
minus 50
in all of that over three x squared and
minus 15x plus 2x minus fifteen plus two
it's minus 13x minus 13x minus ten and
that is choice D choice D next problem
problem 70 boy they want us to keep this
up this is good practice so they write
this problem 70 x squared plus 8x plus
16 over X plus 3 divided by divided by
2x plus 8 over x squared minus 9 so the
first thing you do when you divide by a
fraction that's the same thing as
multiplying by its inverse so this is
equal to x squared plus 8x plus 16 / x
plus 3 times the inverse of this x
squared minus nine over 2x plus eight
fair enough now let's see if we can
simplify these is a little bit I'll do
that in yellow so this is let's see 4
plus 4 is 8 4 times 4 16 so this we can
rewrite as X plus 4 times X plus 4 let's
see x squared minus 9 that's a squared
minus B squared so this we can rewrite
as X plus 3 times X minus 3 let's go in
with the pattern we can factor out a 2
here so we can rewrite this as 2 times X
plus 4 we have an X plus 3 there and of
course when we multiply fractions we're
just multiplying all the numerator over
all the denominators so you saw almost
you can just kind of make this one line
and so the numerator is X plus 4 times X
plus 4 times X plus 3 times X minus 3
all that over X plus 3 times 2 times X
plus 4 so now let's do some cancellation
this is the fun part so we have an X
plus 4 and X plus 4 cancel them out X
plus 4x plus 4 we have an x + 3 + X + 3
cancel them out
3x plus 3 and what are we left with
we're left with we are left with an X
plus 4 times an X minus 3 all of that
over 2 and that is choice C and I will
see you in the next video